have you guys watched I was really into  this recently uh Harry and Megan on  Netflix I thought it was really great  really members my own dear beloved  probably watching right now grandmother  my lovely Nana asked me if I had watched  Harry and Megan and I died  no I'm not Harry and Megan I actually  had to watch part of it for the show  this I I went through it you know on  behalf of the audience that woman gets  more villainous every single day the  disrespect that she shows to the the  woman is dead Okay this like one of the  greatest women of the 20th century is  dead and she's still disrespecting her  on camera and her husband has to watch  it was so it was it was this you were  talking about transgender characters and  movies it was whatever occurred it there  it was much more emasculating the worst  cuckold of all time yeah